hey what's up guys my name is HMO and
welcome back to my syphilis gloss series
today I'm going to be talking about
virtual functions in c++ over the last
two episodes we've been talking about
classes and object-oriented programming
and inheritance and all that stuff and
virtual functions are really really
important to that whole concept virtual
functions allow up to override methods
in subclasses so for example let's say
we've got two classes a and B B is
derived from K many would be the
subclass of a if we create a method in
the a class and marketers virtual we
have the option of overriding that
method in the B class to get it to do
something else as always this is best
explained by an example so let's take a
look and we're to create two clauses
here one's going to be called anti Z
which is going to be our base class the
only thing this empty class is going to
have is a public method called get a
name which is going to return a string
because this is just an entity we're
just going to return the word entity
next we're going to create another class
player which is going to be a subclass
of the entity class we're going to add a
little bit more of this class firstly
we're going to actually store a name
then I'm going to provide a constructor
which allows us to specify a name and
then we're going to give it a method
called get name which in this case is
going to return this name the name that
is the member okay cool so let's take a
look at how we might use this set up
let's see whether we create an ASCII
here and I'm going to try and print the
get name from that FC then I'm going to
create a player I'll call this player
turn on and I'm going to print the
player's name as well and I'm not going
to bother deleting these objects because
this program tonus anyway there's no
just no use in doing that let's get at 5
to write our code and if we look at the
results alright cool looks pretty good
well as you've got show no printing
everything seems fine however everything
that we've written here so far will
crumble if we decide to use a concept of
polymorphism if I start referring to the
player as if it was an entity that's
where we run into problem so for example
if I create a variable here called
empty which is actually going to be
assigned to T which is of course a
pointer to a player type right
player however now I'm just referring to
it as an entity if I print this so I'll
do entity get name if I run micro here
you can see we get entity printing
however we would have course expect
player because even though we're
referring to this entity as an entity
pointer it is actually a player it's an
instance of the player class possibly a
better example is if we had a prince
named function which took in an entity
and then here we just called see out and
see get name and I'll replace these with
print name a and print name P so now
we've got seemingly one function which
takes in any kind of entity of course so
you can see that we don't get any
compile errors when we try to pass in P
because P is an entity right player is
an entity and all we're doing here is
calling the entities get name function
which we would expect to be this get
name for our entity and then this get
name for our player however if we run
our code you consider to get entity
printing twice why is that that's
there's incorrect there instances
happening is because if we just declare
our functions normally our methods
normally inside our classes then when it
comes time to call a method is going to
call whatever method belongs to the type
and of course if we look at this print
main function it takes in an entity
points off meaning that when we call the
get name function inside entity it's
going to look at entity and just call
get name that's it however we want C++
to somehow realize that hang on a minute
the entity that I passed into here is
actually a player so please call this
get name function that is where virtual
functions come in virtual functions that
reduce something called dynamic dispatch
which compile is typically implemented
by our V table a V table is basically
table which contains a mapping for all
the virtual functions but our base class
so that we can actually map them to the
correct overwritten function at runtime
in the future I'm going to do a whole in
depth video on how we tabled work and
all that so stick around for that if
you're interested but to keep it simple
all you basically need to know is that
if you want to override
function you have to mark the base
function in the base bar as virtual
let's go back to our code and I'm just
simply going to add the word virtual to
the front of this get name function that
is in our base up in our entity class it
might not seem like much but this
basically tells the compiler hey
generate a V table for this function so
that if it's overwritten you can point
to the correct function with this change
let's hit f5 to run our code and look at
that
we've got NC and shown on printing
correctly now another thing that we can
do that was introduced in tables of 11
is actually marked this overridden
function with the keyword override right
over here this isn't required of course
you can see that we just ran our code
without that and it worked fine however
you should still do this it goes first
of all it makes it a little bit more
readable since we now know this is
actually an overridden function but also
it just helps us a little bit with
preventing bugs tutors like spelling
mistakes and all that like for example
five types get a name with a lowercase
and you can see we get an error because
there's no such function in the base but
for us to override or if we try an
override function that isn't marked as
virtual you can see it also gives us an
error so it's just something that helps
us out okay so that's basically what a
virtual function is virtual functions
aren't free though unfortunately there
are two runtime costs associated with
virtual functions firstly we have the
additional memory that is required in
order for us to store that be table so
that we can dispatch to the correct
function that includes a member pointer
in the actual base path that points to
the V table and secondly every time we
call a virtual function we have to go
through that table to determine which
function to actually map to which is an
additional performance penalty and
because of these costs some people just
prefer not to use virtual functions at
all honestly in my experience I've never
encountered this to be so costly that
that it would make any difference if I
stopped using virtual functions so
personally I use them all the time
without any issue maybe if you are on
some embedded platform which has
absolutely terrible performance and
every CPU slice accounts maybe then
avoid virtual functions but otherwise I
really can't tell you not to use them
because of performance because because
it's just such a minimal impact that you
probably won't notice it at all hope you
guys enjoyed this video on virtual
functions if you have an expression
comment just leave them below and I'll
see you guys next time goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]